the saints are taking on um the
the uh eagles this weekend and this is a
big game for both teams and the man
who's calling that and who also called
last week on fox the washington football
team beating the bucks one of our
favorites back here on the rich eisen
show mark schlareth how are you mark i'm
doing good you know what rich you're 100
right here in denver they honored mike
shanahan put him in the ring of fame and
then uh they played the raiders and the
raiders acted like it was a rivalry and
uh the broncos played like they had
dinner reservations that they relate to
so
yeah same type of thing here in denver
i'm telling you i think we need to look
that up chris like let's uh let's figure
that one out because that's a deep well
to the saints certainly since the bills
are coming in um so what did you learn
uh watching the bucks come off there bye
week and um and get get hit in the mouth
by the washington football team
mark yeah you know it was really strange
i mean
first and foremost um
they really put a tent kind of
coverage-wise washington did against
uh the bucks they put a tent they
basically said you're gonna throw it
underneath we're gonna rally around and
try to make tackles and it was
interesting because brady tried to
invite uh involve the backs and there
must have been six drops
in that game by running back so they
were consistently behind the chains they
did get loose one time with a big play
over the top to mike evans that brady
was exceptional in but they're just they
were just out of sync and of course they
didn't run the ball i mean it was always
it was always a 13 point 7.9 point
whatever it was game but it just seemed
like they had completely abandoned that
and we're going to win the way we want
to win which is throwing the ball and
and you know and dumping it to the backs
and um ultimately none of that stuff
really worked it was really more about
lack of execution to me on the offensive
side of the ball if they complete those
balls to the backs and they're
every one of them is a catchable ball
you know you're in a you're in a
different ballgame because you're not in
third down and seven you're not in third
down and nine you're in third down and
two and you know that's a much better
place to live obviously as an offense so
but you know how we are in this uh nfl
media world that the bucks are in
trouble they've lost two around to buy
right now and the nfc is wide open and
it's anybody's to win um do you believe
that right now
no do i think they're in trouble oh no i
i mean absolutely not um
you know they're they're a solid
football team they're they're playing
great up front their o line is a really
good they're a really good unit one of
the top units in in football and then
when you just talk about pure talent
rich i mean that like they are the most
talented when you took when you look at
uh chris godwin and mike evans and some
of the secondary players they didn't
even have obviously gronkowski coming
you know he's got the rib injury and um
antonio brown didn't play uh the this
this kid johnson tyler johnson is
playing really well they've got they've
got a
boatload of talent they started i think
eight different corner combinations
through their first nine games
so they've been injured they're gonna
get murphy bunting back they're gonna
get carl davis back
um they're gonna be loaded they're gonna
be absolutely loaded down the stretch
run so i like you hate losing games i i
get that but am i concerned that all of
a sudden they're not going to be good
anymore they're not going to be a
playoff contender or super bowl
contender no not at all i think they're
going to be great so if you have to
place the uh the schlereth mortgage
in-house on an nfc team to make the
super bowl which one would you do it on
which one well green bay i think green
bay is probably under the radar to some
degree because
i think their defense is playing so much
better than anybody gives them credit
for it's hard to focus on anything other
than you know aaron rodgers and
um in the season that he has and the
player that he is but i think green bay
is is probably playing as well as
anybody but you know how this league is
i mean
if if the last two weeks have told you
anything it is more week to week than it
has ever been in any time i can remember
but i would probably if i had a if i had
a
place to bed it'd probably go green bay
right now yeah dallas is you know it's
amazing how you want to talk about week
to week is i mean dallas
gets smoked by denver
and then does the
the deed itself
to atlanta right and then denver itself
goes from playing easily their best game
of the vic fangio era if you want to
call it that easily and it's one of it's
one of bridgewater's best games that
he's played and i know that he he subbed
in febreze and played very well there
too but this is this is teddy's virtuoso
performance and then he olay's big play
sleigh the next week how did that um
how does something like that land in the
locker room when you're watching back on
film well i mean it's it's horrendous um
as a player but
simply because you know especially the
quarterback position
you know everybody everybody on that
team is is you know taking shots for you
right i mean they're they're putting it
on the line so that you can be as good
as you can be and you're doing anything
you can anything you can do to keep
people off your quarterback and for your
quarterback to basically
just sidestep contact you know to not
make a play
that becomes one of those things where
it becomes kind of independent
contractor
and that's the best way to lose football
games when every guy is out there going
i'm gonna you know i'm playing for me
i'm not playing for us
this is not a wii thing this is a me
thing and when you get to that point as
a football team you'll never be any good
and now you look at the broncos in
general
under vic fangio the last two years 13
home games seven of them have been
losses by double digits at home
um you look at you look at right now the
raiders they were uncompetitive in the
end of the game a guy they voted team
captain before the season started uh
cortland sutton end of the game i think
late third quarter
uh teddy bridgewater throws the
interception
and it's being returned and courtland
sutton just walks off the field
doesn't chase it i mean he's your team
captain
and he just quit on that play and then
you get the same thing teddy bridgewater
who you voted team captain does the same
thing on darius slay unacceptable and
that goes to you know that goes to
culture uh that goes to the head coach i
worked as a plumber's apprentice
one summer when i was probably 17 years
old
and i'm working and this guy says uh
this guy says to me hey man i'm going to
teach you everything you need to know
about plumbing
and i basically have a shovel and i'm
digging a ditch down to the septic tank
from this apartment complex we're
building
and he said and i'm like okay man i'm
gonna get everything i need to know
about plumbing right now and he goes
okay you ready i said yes yeah i'm ready
to take it all in right rich
and he says basically i'll clean this up
for the radio poop flows downhill
make sure you've gotta you know make
sure you've got gravity on that on that
pipe you're digging that 50 50 yards of
dirt you're gonna move make sure it's
it's flowing downhill that's all you
need to know and from an organizational
standpoint if your owner or your head
coach doesn't establish and live a
culture every single day it's going to
filter down to the players and the
players are going to take uh culture is
built it's it's the path of least
resistance
and if you if you don't hold people
accountable at the very top of your
organization how do you expect
uh how you play expect the people
underneath you to hold themselves
accountable
and
it's unfortunate because that's not the
demo broncos that i played for and it's
uh you know it's upsetting i mean
elway's the helicopter guy right i mean
for lack of a better phrase
you know what i mean and he's see he's
got to be seeing this too
so
you know that that's what i'm saying
that what what do you do i mean this is
a team that has an opportunity to make
the playoffs this year but i think you
could already see
that they still haven't had the aunt
found the answer at quarterback right
for their future yeah well i mean like
teddy bridgewater is not the future
quarterback of your organization i you
just don't have him on your roster
whoever that guy is he doesn't
he's not part of your roster right now
so
um but again you can still do things the
right way no i know that so do you think
you're you're one of the you if i'm not
mistaken you you sent uh some serious
alarm bells on draft night uh
mark on your twitter feed
is desean watson still or rogers still
uh a possibility here in denver do you
think i think i don't think there's any
question if those guys became available
that uh new general manager
george payton would be you know first in
line um to to see what he could come up
with you know and that's part of moving
von miller and getting a third and a
second and you know doing some of the
deals that he has done
here in in this season to try to uh to
try to get as much draft capital as
possible
because if any of these guys becomes
available if uh the packers decide it's
time to move on i believe without any
doubt um that the broncos would be first
in line to try to make a play that
doesn't mean they'll get him but i think
they'll try to make a play yeah i guess
so i mean the question is though
if you're rogers you know and you if you
do make that move and
you'd want to win now i don't know if
the broncos are would have that leg up
you know like say the steelers might or
um you know uh
and obviously desean watson you know
would would be
would have to realize that there would
still be a process for him if that's
what he's looking for but clearly if
he's okaying south florida and miami he
knows that he's ready for something like
that i just don't know if denver is to
be honest with you yeah i you know rich
i think they're a more talented roster
than
um i think they're more talented roster
than their work then their record would
necessarily indicate right um
and so you know i think they've got some
i think they've got some talented pieces
but
uh i always told my son when he was
coming up in baseball and playing even
in the major leagues you know talents
wasted on talented people um
and it's so much more than talent it
requires so much more
uh talent is is it's really nice to have
but that you know talent um if you don't
have the work ethic and you don't have
the desire and you don't have the you
know all the other intangible aspects to
it tal
really doesn't mean anything
a few more minutes left here with mark
schlereth um you got saints eagles this
week you had i guess i mentioned buck's
washington football team last week the
best team you've seen with your own two
eyes going around the country for fox
this year so far has been which team
mark ooh
that's a um
that is a that's a loaded question
because i've seen different like i've
seen like i think the saints defense is
incredible
obviously offensively they you know they
have to win the way they have to win
they've got to manage trevor simeon
they've got a you know their their
receiving core isn't what it once was um
so that's a you know that's really hard
baltimore did a baltimore game when
they're running the ball they can be
dynamic but the defense has got some
issues i don't know that i've seen
what i would call a complete football
team
over the course of this year on film i
think tampa is the most talented team in
football and i still would probably put
them from all the teams that i've called
as the best team i've called they had a
bad you know they had a bad um result in
the game that i called but i still think
they're uh just studying film and going
back three games and really digging in
and then the game i called i think
they're you know the most talented team
that i've called what about the afc then
which one do you think has got the best
shot here tennessee a game and a half in
front of
uh of the ravens right now um you know
what do you think in the years you know
and this is this is part of the i think
this is part of for me the part of the
problem with the nfl right now um
is
many teams don't have identities and
that's what i love about the tennessee
titans
they know who they are
and
they play to that strength like there's
nothing better than i'll reminisce back
to my playing days in denver if we got
in a second down and short situation and
i'm sitting in the huddle i'm standing
in the huddle waiting i know without
question what plays are getting called
we're either running 18 19 handoff 1415
handoff for qb sneak 100 percent
because we're gonna churn we're gonna
churn first downs we're gonna beat you
up at the line of scrimmage we're gonna
pound you make you defend it we're gonna
get a first down and get three more
downs
and so when you have an identity you
know what's coming
you set your jaw and you prepare
yourself
and that's how you impose your will upon
other teams you know what you're good at
and it's it's very much like global gym
we're better than you and we know it and
here we go
and that's tennessee to me they know
what they are right they just there's no
there's not one guy on that team that
questions what the philosophy is uh what
the identity is they know what they're
gonna do
and there's not only can you execute it
because it's what you do all the time
right so you're gonna be better at
executing it but there is a comfort in
knowing what you are and i think there's
a lot of teams
that
week to week they want to be something
other than they are they want to be
special they want to do something um you
know outside the box and
more often than not it's kind of like
the new england patriots you uh you lose
more games than you win and they just
kind of wait around for you to make
mistakes and capitalize on those
mistakes and you know that's where i'm
at that's what i i i hear you mark and
that's why we're talking about teams in
week 10 that are quote unquote back you
know the patriot way appears back the
chiefs looked like the chiefs that with
their identity and you could say
anything about the 49ers another
shanahan coach team like running it 40
times putting debo in the backfield to
get him away from jaylen ramsey throwing
it over the middle to kill no matter
what
um you know
that's
that's the stuff and there has to be
some sort of i guess
metric in in knowing your identity and
and then playing to it to success the
49ers you mentioned them i could see
them winning seven of the next eight
games and being a legit playoff
contender i mean that game was going on
i sent my wife upstairs with a dog and
you know went to the study put a tie on
the doorknob that thing was like i mean
they're just physically whipping the
snot out of people short and necks i
mean that's my kind of football i was
like oh i'm in i'm in on this this is
awesome tying the doorknob means what uh
what's that mean
i need to be left alone right now
off the bears watching football
papa bear thanks for coming on this show
man let's do this more often you take
care of yourself anytime rachel thank
you that's mark schlereth you can catch
him in uh
on fox with adam amin saints and eagles
this week hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here